ohne luca wäre diese welt wie ein lachs
ohne wasser der youtube user mit dem
namen hormon hat mir vor einiger zeit
ein video geschenkt indem er gesagt hat
ich hätte da noch eine frage darf man
eines liebes lied für dich schreiben
daraufhin habe ich in einem meiner
videos darauf reagiert und gesagt ja
dafür fährt auch wir gerade angekommen
meine damen und herren und ja da kann
man auch mal klatschen das horn hat nun
nämlich ein lied hochgeladen was heißt
liebeslied für konkreter bzw luca könnt
euch dieses liebeslied ich habe es extra
für den guten luca komponiert viel spaß
danke an der stelle horn ich habe ja vor
einiger zeit schon auf deine katja die
parodie reagiert die war atemberaubend
sein leistung ist gesund
ich glaube ihr habt das noch gar nicht
gesehen und zwar habe ich jetzt da oben
hier in meinem aufnahme zimmer hier voll
viel fanpost und so immer hängen also
wenn ihr auch briefe oder zeichnungen
oder irgendwie sowas an mehr für mich
habt dann schickt die einfach an
main-post ich hab' ich habe kein
postfach
soll ich mir mein postfach machen dann
schreibt mal in die kommentare und dass
man neigt er hat eigentlich ganz nah
sein könnt ihr mir da auch sachen
hinsehen und dann mache ich einmal im
monat irgendwie sonst wie die arbeiter
darum soll es heute gar nicht gehen
hallo mein name ist toll
warum bist du in meinem aufnahme zimmer
ab und ihr seht jetzt einzelnen track
für luca ich gönne mir solange diese
litt pizza
jetzt kommt ein liter dreck und sie
günstig so lange diese leute pizza
das hormon eigentlichen er oder sie also
just do it hat mir schon alles gegeben
[Musik]
diese eclipse einfach nur krass
wann sind denn ab ohne luca wäre diese
welt die entlassene wasser ohne luca
wäre diese welt wie ein lachs ohne
wasser man so was schönes hat mir noch
nie jemand gesagt möchte
möchtest du mich heiraten ich habe hier
samen oder kölner für dich du bist wie
ein baum augen hast mein herz gestohlen
ich liebe video von
über die sich mega viel mühe geben die
wirklich eine menge menge zeit in die
vorproduktion stecken also was man da
vorbereiten muss die kaufen sachen ein
die überlegen sich irgendwelche regie
büchern dann gibt es mich ich bekomme so
ein liebeslied und reagiert dann darauf
ich habe mir übrigens gerade im übelsten
später an der ist mega gemütlich den
gibt es im erst ging es mir schlecht
dann gut
letztlich war mir klar der luca wer ist
da
lukas da schreibt man die kommentare
geht es euch auch manchmal schlecht und
dann gut und dann merkte der luca ist da
nämlich kommentiere kommentiere
horror um das ist sowas von 2017 wenn du
kommentiert kommentiert ergibt keinen
sinn aber jolo dass das ist dass das ist
das wunder schönste liebeslied das bier
geschrieben wurde und wer hat nur die
diamanten gestohlen um sie in deinen
augen zu verstecken
[Gelächter]
das von queen spur sich das anzugucken
[Musik]
juli was machst du denn hier
kollege hat jetzt das horror holen das
war es jetzt auch sehr gut shop lukasz
ob das war's jetzt hier vom video das
war es jetzt hier vom bio
[Musik]
ich glaube dass gerade sollte so ein
bisschen mein auto darstellen wo ich
auch mal sage der stelle wird das
heutige video dann allerdings auch
beenden wenn es euch gefallen hatte das
gerne mal ein leica schreibt immer eine
kommentare ob ich mir wirklich mal ein
postfach auf machen soll und freunde
macht ihr auch mal irgendwelche videos
auf die ich reagieren soll und lade die
hier auf youtube hoch falls ihr ein
handy oder eine kamera habt oder keine
ahnung was könnte ja einfach mal irgend
welche videos selbst machen die lustig
sind so wie jetzt irgendwie das was das
hormon hier gemacht hat und könnt ihr
einfach meine kommentare schreiben das
dem video gemacht hat und dann werde ich
darauf eventuell das nächste mal
reagieren vielleicht eine ansage an mich
oder vielleicht ja auch ein lied oder
keine ahnung irgendwie was also ich bin
dabei